hey you why don't you turn that great
idea you got just rattling around in
your brain into something real with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing some work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a beautiful website by
yourself but if you get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help you
out
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain happy 4/20 everybody and
welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig very
excited about this 4/20 centric episode
we're talking to koala puffs today as
you probably know her online maybe you
know her as Angela in her real human
persona but she's an amazing youtuber
and content creator that was really
making waves in the cannabis community
we talked all about that we talked about
her being born in Ukraine and a
conservative household and how that has
gotten her to living in Los Angeles with
three dogs smoking weed all day every
day and making it accessible and
educational for young people old people
everyone she just had such a lovely
energy I like everything that she's up
to and things that she's doing in a
world that I don't really know much
about so it was educational for me and I
hope you guys enjoy this episode of not
too deep with koala puffs how
appropriate
oh okay
koala pups is here aka Angela a koala
puffs all these things I am so excited
that you're here
I have a billion questions I think
you're such a fascinating person and the
way I like to kind of start things with
people that have a very interesting
brand and world is by asking what's your
deal I've gathered that much but I think
that you're doing something really cool
so for some people that don't know who
you are at all like how do you describe
what you what you do and what you create
I describe that I create skits and
YouTube videos that are all related to
cannabis in some way so that people that
smoke and have a really safe place and
kind of fun and educational escape to
get to because a lot of people don't
have accepting friends and households
that are cool 4/20 lifestyle so yeah
it's so interesting to me because when I
look at your social media it's a lot
which is very fun but it's also it's
just very fun and silly and also there's
a lot of focus on like acceptance and
like you said and like education and
providing a safe space for people
because you know I grew up with dare
programs with all of that [ __ ] that
really tries to make marijuana this
demon devil creature that once it infest
your life you're ruined for the rest of
your days and I think you're doing a
really fun job of just making it normal
for lack of a better word like it should
be normal like I mean we yeah people
drink online all the time and I feel
like there's some weird dichotomy
between like smoking and drinking that
like one is totally fine and the other
is very salacious and scandalous and I
like that you're just like here it is
all of it out loud how did you get into
this because I read that you've only
started smoking
like four years ago is that true yeah so
I tried smoking when I was 18 and I
smoked with a person that didn't do a
very good job educating me on cannabis
didn't prepare me for what I'm gonna
feel and what I'm gonna go through right
gave me too much THC so I had a very bad
experience and kind of had a bad mindset
on it and was one of those people that
really just didn't want to be around it
didn't want to talk to my friends about
it even if they were smoking weed I just
kind of kept myself away from it yeah
then four years ago I started you know
hanging out with people that smoke weed
and they kind of introduced me to it
again and I it changed my life I used to
have a really hard time eating so it
helped I never considered myself a
creative person and now I can't stop the
creativity from notice I became much
more once I started my account I became
more accepting of myself I I had a very
tough upbringing and I was very bullied
very judged very blamed everything on
from friends family and I don't want
people to feel that way and I wanted
people to even if it started with just
cannabis you know to not feel judged for
anything for being weird from being
loved or having you know I don't know if
we just wanted to smoke yeah I think
that's I think that's very very lovely
and I think that's one of the things
that people don't talk about around weed
so much is like the beneficial things it
does for you even just talking about
like eating and talking about like
creativity everyone looks at it as this
like thing that's going to decrease all
of that and take that all away from you
and you're just gonna become some like
potato on a couch and hope for the best
what was it about this like time four
years ago that changed it for you was it
just that it was presented by people
that cared more or that it just was like
handled more gently it was all of the
above it was the environment which I
think is
important I think doing any [ __ ] I think
even drinking around people they give
you bad energy creates adapt atmosphere
about Association yeah yeah absolutely
so it was the group of people that were
getting me back into it they were very
very like go at your own pace not too
forceful but also like very educational
like you're gonna have dry mouth you're
gonna have the munchies you're gonna
feel everything like it's not weird like
except right and yeah I remember the
first meal I had after I like course
we've got really high and I knew that
the munchies were normal and I was like
I want to be all the time and my friends
are like you're eating like a baby
dinosaur we found that like new people
start smoking weed and go through this
excitement base yeah and that made me
feel so okay about the way that I was
feeling is going through it and that
people knew that I was high but it was
fine like it wasn't that yeah it was
accepted yeah I was born and raised in
Ukraine so I come from where like
everything is frowned upon
like she's before marriage you was found
upon what I would eat live in Ukraine
you know because you yeah you were born
and raised in Ukraine and you moved here
when you were like eleven ten okay which
is such a huge shift you moved here and
so obviously there's it's a night and
day I'm sure for you moving here and
then introducing gears later all of this
into your world what and now even you
smoke with your mom which blows my mind
and is like the cutest thing I've ever
seen I have so many questions around
that like how did how did coming from
Ukraine with presumably like parents
that are probably more strict and rigid
evolved into now you have a weed brand
and your mom smokes with you sometimes
listen risks had to be made I mean my
mom and I had to go to therapy or for
our relationship to get to the point
where we are now because I was smoking
weed and it was drifting us apart even I
wanted it to bring us closer together
because
there were all these new things in my
life that I was experiencing from a an
emotional and mental point of view
smoking and also just once my channel
started growing all the experiences and
all the new things that happen you know
how it totally it's wild was only
focusing on the cannabis part and I am
so happy that we went to therapy and
talked about it and I was able to
explain without her feeling attacked
that this is important to me and I
really do feel like people need me and I
need them and it's like this is where I
feel like I belong I can't I can't walk
away from this but I also don't want to
have a terrible relationship with you
for the rest of our lives
Wow and I mean kudos to you for having
that conversation with a parent which is
beyond difficult to do yeah Cheers I'm
sure but like taking that risk you have
this reward now where your mom at least
on camera you guys seem like you had a
great relationship going that's great
she's here right now cooking up a storm
in the kitchen right now amazing okay so
what's when was the first time that you
ever smoked with your mom so it was
about I want to say like a year ago or
like nine months ago there was actually
a video on YouTube I lived with Magda's
all for 20 started filming a YouTube
video together and halfway through like
it was a Q&A for my mom and I'm like
will you smoke with me because people
kept also asking like when will you
smoke with your daughter to answer all
the questions she was willing to sit
next to but she's like no I don't want
it was the end of the video and I was
like alright um I asked one more time do
you take a puff in me and she was like
okay I do and I was like what oh my god
I was freaking out we started collecting
joints through the house looking to make
sure it was like a hybrid that was a lot
more indica dominant that didn't give
her anxiety uh my roommate and I were
just like this water because she's gonna
need water
yeah just like two little helper bees
like lead into her lungs before she
changed her mind
so
yeah getting everything and she smoked
and she didn't mind it she smoked
cigarettes her whole life so I'm trying
this is a would I consider a much
healthier alternative perhaps that
everyone that way but that's how I look
at it sure
and yeah this was about like I said like
about nine months ago and where she's
try I'm aid homemade edibles the other
day she's tried some of those she took I
I will load up a bomb for her I'll load
up the chambered she'll take a little
pop at the top oh my gosh he takes babe
hits my mom's a straight-up G like what
a sweetheart I wanted a real true
testament of love for a daughter by like
really taking a step into that world
that's so sweet
yeah and I think it really just like
showed her that it's not this big bad
wolf hmm you know takes you in turns you
into a bad person it really just what
you make of it you know you've got to be
able to handle your liquor you gotta be
right handle your weed that's not a
hundred percent I couldn't agree more
the now you have what looks like the
most unbelievable collection of every
possible thing in the cannabis world I
the fun thing because I only started
smoking more frequently within the last
year and I have loved the the benefits
of it more than I did when I was younger
cuz I just loved drinking so much and
the amount of devices and things that
have been created in this industry blows
my mind yeah your collection looks
insane what is the most insane thing I
don't even know what to call it piece
that you own I would have to say I have
this stupid glass or student glass
gravity bong huh Rotech and show it to
you I'm sure please do rotate so you
basically can put the whole blunt in
here if you want to and just keep
rotating it and it'll keep blowing smoke
out of the other and separating
on his feed like a long time ago and
then it just kind of became like a
must-have and I I was able to get my
hands on it luckily and so though to be
my craziest piece for sure that is
bonkers looking it looks like you have a
full chemistry lab set up in your place
it's beyond crazy to me that's what it
feels like how do you clean this stuff
the other side I'm looking at all this
glassware and I'm like how do you how do
you do that so I did and every stoner
began with like rubbing alcohol and salt
situation okay they got to the point
where every time I tried to cook there
wouldn't be any salt so yeah and then I
found through Instagram different
cleaning solutions I mostly use
resolution and it basically just like
you put it in your phone you coded you
shake it up and it just removes all your
stuff and then you just got to do a good
job at rinsing it out once man they're
usually reusable so you can just like go
through all your pieces it's a pain in
the butt trust me it's like bathing all
your children right I've broken many
pieces just cleaning them but sure but
that's the thing too looking at it you
know you think of it as this like stoner
whatever activity and then you're like
no there's maintenance and upkeep and
like you have to be pretty like
meticulous about all of that so there's
a whole other level of like organization
I think that's probably at play for you
too which blows my mind I got a whole
room dedicated to just all my smoking
stuff so that's all over the house
walk-in closet or smoking room you know
you're a professional this is your
business
this is how you do it what um what do
you suggest as like a starter kit for
people that are curious in this world I
think a lot of people start with a dry
pipe and I say we need to let that go
everybody should have a good experience
starting out with at least a water
bubbler okay you or joint but don't
don't hurt yourself with dry pipes but
if you are introducing somebody or you
who are introducing yourself definitely
go in the hybrid range like I said
earlier into consumption it is very good
we don't want anxiety levels we don't
want stress right
usually when we experience something for
the first time its new and we already
kind of freak out a little bit cuz sure
you sue it so that's why going the
indica route or the indica dominant it's
100% what I would recommend and nobody
nearby okay that's key that makes sense
what so now you're a prominent person in
this cannabis industry
what is the cannabis industry like I
have no knowledge of it at all oh it's
amazing
okay everybody is so friendly like I
mean just like every in every situation
there's the occasional person that you
don't get along with origins there's an
[ __ ] everywhere yeah but you know for
the most part everybody really is just
gathering for the love of the plant and
what it how it helps us bring people
together we could sit there and talk
about how a plant smells for a solid 30
minutes who you're talking to you know
right if you like it's very bonding
because when you smoke together like
even you could just see from me and my
mom it just brings a whole other level
of connecting yeah boyfriends and
girlfriends and husbands and wives like
I really think that it's important to
share that with each other if one wants
you to try the other sure but yeah I
don't know I just did everybody's pretty
like stoned all the time every go
there's not very many fights which I
really like
they're wonderful there's a lot of
conversations they get lots of you know
stoner ooh stoner thoughts get a lot of
conversations going bring lots of people
and it just feels like a really great
community of people that just want to
get high together and don't want to harm
anybody and just amazing there's
something very pure and lovely about
that is there any stigma or any
strangeness being a female in the
industry almost I feel like there's I I
went through that hump like what a lot
of people were messaging me that I could
do something better with my life as a
woman and they just irritated me because
it's just like well first of all what do
you mean as a woman like wouldn't I like
I could do everything a man can do but I
could do it in heels yeah exactly
and I can bleed from my vagina while
doing it so I you try that I'm at yeah
and also it was just like this is the
fact that I chose like I this is for the
first time in my life I feel like I
belong and for the four people that feel
like they're in they felt that before
we'll understand how you will never want
to leave that spot when you feel like
this is where you belong and this is
where you're meant to do yeah I mean
that's the big thing right is we're all
striving to be part of a community
that's like why YouTube exists it's why
we all interact on social medias because
we all want to feel like we're part of
something or connecting to something and
so who cares what it is if you feel a
sense of you know connection with people
and like that you belong somewhere and
you have purpose somewhere that's
beautiful exactly and nobody is getting
hurt like I don't see the harm of that
yeah we'll come around as I said before
people don't like new I say this about
myself
I don't like shares and we'd to a lot of
people is new you know it's and even if
it's not new it was never spoken about
in a very positive way even just my
media and the way the commercials have
made it look through years yeah yeah
it's demonized it's this it's this
monster that's gonna take you over it's
drug drug is bad that's what everyone
associate you ate grass oh you're never
going back
so you've called yourself an activity
stoner is that right and that means that
basically you get high and you enjoy
activities which is beautiful because
when I get high my activity is laying
down and just watching reality TV and
not believing what I'm seeing more than
when I'm sober but what are your top
three activities that you get into 100%
some kind of a game or puzzle and
filming a YouTube video because I love
capturing it and being able because the
same thing with smoking is when you're
drinking you don't think you're that
high yeah wrong right and then you watch
the footage bag you're like where are my
eyes I was I thinking about thank you
why didn't I read the directions to the
game and actually so that's my number
one favorite thing grabbing some random
game either on Amazon or in my cabinet I
have a game cabinet and just starting a
film a YouTube video YouTube just like
is a great escape for me personally I
recommend it to everybody I love it do
you have you posted anything that you've
either taken down or has there been any
videos you've shot that haven't seen the
light of day um I have I have a lot of
videos that I have on deck because this
quarantine has just had a very big
emotional toll on me with my everything
else that goes on in our personal lives
outside of that so I wanted to knock out
a bunch of video so I could take an
emotional break from having to film so
many so there are those videos that
haven't been seen yet but they're going
to be coming up other than that once I
film something I feel like I put my
heart and time into it and I that's what
I wanted at the time and I feel like
it's important to put it out there right
and yeah I don't think there's anything
that I like how back oh god bless you
it's the transparency that's so lovely
they're just like here it all is take it
or leave it
yeah I show myself smoking weed on the
toilet and once you
very true very true okay we're gonna
take a quick break when we get back we
have more questions for koala pops we'll
be right back with more knot you're deep
[Music]
now is the time more than ever to turn
that a dream of yours into reality and
guess who can help you out
it is Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
if you're looking to start a new
business showcase your work published
content sell products more Squarespace
is the tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks so
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself
they also have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box so there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you can get the help you need
with their 24/7 award-winning customer
support they empower millions of
people's from designers to lawyers
artists to gamers even restaurants and
gyms to turn great ideas into something
real so head to squarespace.com slash
Grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace ok back
with quelle puffs who has been the
biggest or what has been the biggest
influence on on your lifestyle obviously
marijuana but like has there been a
person has there been anything along the
way that's impacted you I have been
super influenced by Kevin Hart I know
that might sound a little strange to say
just cuz I feel like he worked so hard
he went on so many tours he's so much he
did so many Santa shows a wild filming
movies and there were so many movies
that were popping out at the same time I
don't know what it is just him being so
happy and just I just kind of I just
relate to him and I just AM
inspired by him and I'm sure that person
he's made some mistakes as as everybody
else but I've been various by inspired
by how hard he's worked and how much
he's accomplished that's cool I can see
similar energy there thank you well
speaking of movies you have a movie that
you're in for 20 appropriate what a
stretch well tell us about this so it's
a super fun movie I'm really excited to
be a part of it I'm actually the only
influencer that's a part of it so I was
very nervous to be included because
there are all these real actors that
have been in real things and then they
just brought me and that just blurts out
random things all the time that's
wonderful
and also so intimidating yeah it's very
intimidating but the group and the crew
and the cast was just so amazing at the
movies basically it meant to be watched
every 420 to celebrate the day it is
basically about all the different types
of stoners and about a dispensary that's
trying to stay open by introducing a new
very amazing strange of the world and
the rest you guys will just have to
watch to find out but I promise that's
so exciting how was the experience
shooting it um we were pretty to scram
to do it all in a short timeframe to get
it all it and ready by forge money so
they were pretty long days but I was so
excited we got to like I said work with
so many really great people I'm never
I'm only so when I moved to California I
actually did background on shows and
maybe yeah
cast in a movie and we had seen
background being brought in and that's
what I used to do and ya seen the full
circle in like the six and a half years
that I've lived here it was just the
most surreal moment I've experienced so
far that's bonkers also talk to me about
background work how was that what was
that like oh yeah I've heard
stories but I would love to hear your
personal account of it I wouldn't
recommend it it's a lot of work for a
little pay and a little bit of food it
seems like you're mostly waiting around
a lie or you're booked up as many people
and you're getting filmed the whole time
but like you're not important so you
have to be quiet you can't talk you
can't like you know you can't walk away
you're like because they might need you
at any second it's very very little pay
its minimum wage so that's the way it is
that's what it went with yeah bye are
there any movies or TV shows out there
that we might see you in the background
of oh yeah I did I got booked at the
cheerio on the last season of Glee so
pretty much most of that season I was on
that amazing oh my god what else there's
there's so many there's entourage there
is oh my god this is like a fun Easter
egg hunt for your fans to go through and
try and find you a couple of days of
background in porn a screen shot okay
two things what one kudos to you for
having a broad spectrum of work at - I
didn't know that that was a thing that
you could be a background actor in a
porn and that's what a very scandalous
teen for example on a school bus okay to
be a bunch of schoolgirls that sitting
on the bus already that are like
wondering what's going on all these
people are being because nobody would
stop the bus and get off you know be
like so
that is your back or background or if
you like we did a bar see there was a
parse Wow
listen it's free porn right in front of
you
they let you film if you want they don't
care if you FaceTime your mom they're
like you know they pay way more than
regular they have way better craft
services Wow
so I'm sure it in comparison your mom's
probably pretty into what you're doing
now as long as I mean that's the safest
porn background to present to a parent
but you were in a porn fully clothed
very crazy fun experience like every
person that was doing background there
was very open sexually so we had fun
conversation during lunch time Wow that
kind of background you know honestly I
would recommend once or twice you meet a
lot of people you make some good
connections you have some like nice
conversations what's to lose there's
nothing honest you'll get you literally
like you'll become friends with some
point stars or is there really nothing
bad about that is I got some really good
tips I've been I've been crushing the
dating game here with the tips I learned
okay yeah that's uh that's quality stuff
I mean that's priceless information yeah
exactly
oh I did want to ask you okay so you
adopted a koala is this true or you you
sponsor one so yes somebody gifted me
one for my birthday a couple of years
ago oh wow so and then I went ahead and
another one once the fires were going on
and then I realized that it would
probably just help a lot more to just
try to raise money for these
organizations in Australia that are
actually helping and going out there and
saving these animals and providing the
medical care so we did a live stream
where I ate a milligram for every dollar
that was donated Wow we split it up on
three different organizations and I did
a match I was willing to do it up to ten
thousand dollars so all together we
raised like fifty seven hundred for the
three organizations combined Wow and
that you you must be I must have been
feeling pretty good really so we broke
it up in two different days when we took
the edibles and I had a friend that was
helping me but just through that one
live stream we donate we got twelve
hundred dollars donated to in like 30
minutes to amazing organizations yeah
that's incredible do you have a bucket
list or some people that you most want
to smoke within a video Oh Miley Cyrus
no no sir yeah Seth Rogan yeah Joe Rogan
all the Rogen's I feel like you could
manifest this I feel like this can
happen for you I would really love that
I have gotten a chance to smoke with one
person that I never thought I would that
was pretty famous I can't mention the
name just out of privacy but it
definitely blew my mind again how
cannabis can just make the most
outrageous things happen that you never
thought would amazing yeah what's the
like what's the the most popular
feedback that you get from your
Instagram or your YouTube channel or
what's the most common feedback that you
get the most thing that I see the thing
that I see the most has got to be just
people saying that they appreciate that
I'm myself
um I frequently have boogers in my nose
and I am okay with it I showed myself
trimming my nose
there's like I show off my pimples like
we you know I named my pimples we kinda
embrace everything that's natural and
the most I think feedback is people have
really become more okay with who they
are because they're or so they say
because I am publicly being you know
showing that doesn't matter what you got
going on it is totally okay own it and
that's what keeps me going
honestly especially during a time like
this it frequently makes me question
what am I doing this for why in my army
is me filming these videos isn't doing
it I'm sure you have the same thing oh
girl yeah that it's that is what I'm
doing trite kind of thing does this
matter
what really matters could I be doing
something better and I think there is a
big demand for people wanting to see
exactly what you're doing I want you to
continue doing it and want you to be
every emotion that you're feeling and
it's really nice because I feel like I
could ingenuine ly be angry or be sad or
be hurt or be happy and feel hyper
bouncing off the walls and I can go on
my Twitter or Instagram or snapchat and
it's completely accepted and it's so
again an occasional [ __ ] that's gonna
be like all usual stop being you're like
you're not the first person to tell me
this so it doesn't affect me and I'm I
you know that jerk that goes out of my
way to say like no like I'm not gonna
stop being this way because I prevented
me from being me because of people like
you for so long and I am done yeah
another person like you prevent me from
being me and prevent other people from
being themselves like that's you need to
take your toxic energy away good for you
snap snap snaps all the way around okay
so you did a movie you're doing your
YouTube and you're also doing music I
did have a song that came out it's
called smoking by myself totally
nothing's aligned the movie the song and
I honestly
I'm just very grateful for my manager
Seth he popped into my life a couple of
months before Christmas and has been
able to take a lot of work off my
shoulders and help me do things that I
don't think I would have been able to do
on my own
so I'm very I hope he's listening right
now thank you sir Joseph and the dad has
been you know he presents the
opportunity on the table and I'm always
found to try something as long as I feel
comfortable and and you know I tried to
give my hundred percent and whether it's
the best thing that's out there or not I
am not ashamed of anything then you know
we're putting out there and I'm really
really happy that I've been able to
branch out and try so many new things
and have such a supportive feedback from
my fan that's amazing is there going to
be more music so we were working on some
more music but I wasn't completely in
love with it and I want to feel it away
with my music that I do with my videos I
want to like rewatch them and we listen
over and over and be loved so we started
from scratch for right now put the other
two songs and we were working on on the
side and kind of trying to come up with
something new now so possum we're
definitely going to try to release some
more music I just don't know when
cool good for you for having standards
and wanting to make sure that it's the
best it can be
I think people appreciate that even if
they have to wait yeah thank you I
appreciate you saying that
of course okay we're gonna take one last
break when we get back we have a bunch
of Twitter questions for you we'll be
right back with more not too deep so
we're all in it we're all going through
it right now and here's something that
might be able to help you out you're
stuck at home feeling isolated worried
about the state of the world in your
life and your relationships it's better
help they offer online professional
counselors who can help you can talk to
a licensed online therapist and find
relief better help therapists specialize
in issues like depression stress anxiety
relationships and saamne family
conflicts basically every single thing
that all of us are experiencing at the
current moment I know that I've been
going through peaks and valleys hi
and lows ups and downs all of it and
having someone to talk to
it's just such a relief even for the
most minor things conversationally or
the most deep major things
conversationally
you can connect with your counsellor in
a safe and private online environment
anything you share is confidential you
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your needs and you get matched
with a counselor that you'll love in
less than 24 hours you can easily
schedule secure video or phone sessions
with your therapist plus exchange
unlimited messages and if for any reason
you're unhappy with your counselor you
can request a new one at any time for no
additional charge you can get
professional help when you want it
wherever you are better help is a truly
affordable option and you guys will get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so why not get
started today go to better help calm
slash grace that's better help calm
slash grace discount code grace talk to
a therapist online and get help okay
koala puffs before we get into these
Twitter questions I'm going to ask you
the two questions I asked every single
guest that is on the podcast the first
is who alive or dead would you most want
to throw cold spaghetti at I did I don't
know why but Justin Bieber is the first
person that popped into my head and I
don't know maybe one food fight or maybe
not I don't know it would be fun to find
out where that would go yeah I feel like
that would be a very pleasant tick-tock
to watch I yeah I you know what I feel
we gotta give it a try now yeah I think
this can happen I think you smoked me
with Miley Cyrus you both go to his
house and you throw some cold spaghetti
on them and then you see where the day
takes you it either it's gonna go really
bad or really good so I roll the dice
okay the other question I ask every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or close call a
bathroom related incident but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so mine for example is college
jogging front lawn
okay mine unfortunately is almost
yesterday after mushroom I've been there
and that is a very dangerous experience
especially when you catch your
reflection on mushrooms in a mirror and
you get distracted and it takes a second
to reorient yourself your body doesn't
stop working when your brains off
somewhere else okay clarify did not [ __ ]
my pants I made it by the oh yeah yeah
it's a it's a very sensitive beast okay
let's get into these Twitter questions
for you okay let's see
Oh cushy pines 37 wants to know if you
could go back and tell your younger self
about now what would you say yeah we
you're not gonna believe this you're
gonna be very fair okay your button
alias asked would you ever start a
podcast of your own I've considered it I
wanted to do like ad or anything but I
wanted to do deer koala I was just a
little concerned because I do have such
a comedic crowd that I go with my things
that if the advice got a little serious
and my comedy would be taken as an
insensitivity when I would just want to
be brightening the mood so that was my
only concert that I haven't gone that
route but so kind of marinating on the
idea I think you can marry those
together I think there's a way that you
can make that happen
an imperial yeah I'm curious to see how
it works I think that could be really
nice we should say why not brandy wants
to know being in the cannabis industry
what do you find is the hardest thing
and then she asked do people take you
less serious is it being hot is it hard
being able to go out in public
I love how connected you stay with your
fans
become too much oh my goodness okay
being in the cannabis industry what's
the hardest part I think they're the
hardest part is not putting too much
pressure on yourself because once you're
more so cannabis public you feel like
the world is putting pressure on you
with how frequently you gotta release
content or what type and at the end of
the day it's just on your in your mind
and there that was really difficult for
me to learn but I did and I feel great
bludsoe I feel like the most difficult
thing is to just not put so much
pressure on yourself yeah just go with
it yeah do you feel it must feel
sometimes the pressure of having to only
create cannabis content I don't mind
that at all yeah I usually have a harder
time outside of the cannabis content
because I feel like everything else has
already been done and done in the best
way possible so for my stepping in China
sure yeah but yeah I don't know I think
it is well the other part of that
question too and I'm curious about this
because you are to a great degree you
make a point to be so interactive with
your fans on all social media platforms
does that ever become too much for you
oh yes all the time yeah it's worth it
it the amount of people that tell me
that I get them through the day or
through some difficult times that
they're going through or just you know
how I taught them something about
cannabis and introduce them to some
things that they didn't know about it
makes all the little
[ __ ] dm's and irritating little
things that people say like worth it
because and in the long run with the
impact that I feel like I'm making is
lasting longer than the impact that
these rude comments are making on me so
totally that's a great way to see it
someone to know how is it living with
three dogs now you three dogs I just
adopted a new dog yesterday yes his name
is
I see the German Shepherd I have a
Chihuahua named Tony and a pitbull named
Aria and actually thank you to Twitter
somebody tweeted me a week ago and said
that somebody was fostering a dog and
they're fostering situation wasn't
working out and because he was so big
you might have a difficult time getting
adopted would I be able to take another
dog in so I just put my dogs in the car
and with social distancing tried to
introduce our dogs and our Lau and see
if they like would at least get along so
that we wasn't aggressive towards people
and towards animals and we signed the
adoption papers yesterday at 11:30 in
the morning he's officially ours Wow
congratulations amazing you have a House
of pups now I love dogs so much I love
animals in general but I'm definitely
Way just way way way more of a dog
person than anything else and so having
I used to live in a crew in Koreatown in
a studio apartment where like my dog
aria and I barely fit so to be able to
see yourselves here now so many years
later like four and have be able to fit
basically a horse of a German Shepherd
provide our yard for Aria that's beneath
us been cooped up with me just because
helping me with my anxiety through the
years is really nice to see oh that's so
sweet
okay some wants to know what is a hidden
talent or what is a talent that you wish
you had I wish I could draw a man piece
of paper and like and just like create
the most magical things and my stick
figures look messed up I just would
definitely please I wish I could have
someone teach my brain how to draw I
love that I know I know that feeling too
I've when I've done mushrooms before
that I really get into a moment where I
think I'm the most amazing artist that
I'm like suddenly it's clicked in and
this paintings gonna be so beautiful and
people are gonna be so
shock that I've had this hidden talent
for years and then the next morning I
look at it I'm like that is garbage
that's straight trash oh god this is a
copy of exactly what I'm seeing yeah and
then the next day I we were checking out
and I was like let's just leave these
paintings here the Airbnb owner because
like I don't need to keep this is bad
like this is the gift I'm giving back to
the universe right now here's your tip
for giving us a great house to chip on
someone to know what do you see for the
future of the cannabis industry and the
entertainment world I see the cannabis
industry expanding and becoming way more
accepted through the years and the more
that we provide education and introduce
our friends and family members the right
way to it the faster we could get there
and the into cannabis entertainment I'm
really excited to see honestly the one
thing I really look forward to is seeing
cannabis commercials at the Super Bowl
man that's so true I know that it's
coming one day and I hope that I hope
it's sooner rather than later and I just
like all the movies that are coming out
and how much it's much more accepted on
Netflix and shows and there's a new
streaming service kwibi that's coming up
that's called 420 friendly you have some
more content on there so I'm really
think it's Super Bowl one day it's gonna
happen I'm gonna stand up and I'm gonna
be like I hope you're yelling at the
commercial and that you're also in the
commercial that you're yelling at in the
same sweater just with the mushrooms on
it just screaming at them because I mean
I'm happy with how long this took
okay last question before we wrap up
what's the weirdest thing you've made a
bowl from oh I've definitely done some
weird things I feel like you get very
very creative with you I'm like I mean
I've done fruits vegetables pizzas the
ground oh I've done that one of those
like the head rests in a car where you
put a joint in one end and you smoke it
out the other end it just goes all
around them and what I don't I can't
even bring that so you know the head
rest in your car oh yeah the two snakes
coming out of it yeah put it in mine and
you put your lip seats on the other and
you're just like smoke I don't know why
you do Wow hey I mean that's creative
unnecessary but you know what try it
once or twice and then you know how you
move on for this podcast right we
appreciate it
koala we've come to the end of the
podcast but before this all wraps up we
normally when we record these in person
have a personalized fortune cookie that
we give to our guests but because we're
doing this remotely we sent you a little
file that's a digital fortune cookie
that has a personalized fortune in it
just for you let me know if you--if you
got it if you want to open that and read
us what the fortune is picture the
cookie and then in a picture could be
opened and unfortunately 20/20 does not
pass the vibe track the vibe has passed
this expiration and will be available
for the renewal possibly by 2021
man what a fortune can we just throw the
whole 20/20 away and start fresh for
2020 while I described let's cleanse
let's cleanse
i'm gonna fake-eat the cookie now love
it love it
okay cool puffs this has been so lovely
it's been so fun to hear about your
world where can people find you and
everything you're doing if they don't
already know
honestly if you just search koala puffs
on the beautiful world of sea Google's
Instagram Twitter and YouTube will come
up I also have my website Qualcomm that
has all of those social channels link
there and much more so so yeah and you
also have a bunch of really cute merch I
want to add for anyone out there looking
for fun shirts it's very cute
I have that they bring me weed and it is
known that if you wear it somebody will
eventually bring you eat so you must
have it what a beautiful guarantee again
thank you so much guys make sure you go
check her out also watch 4:20 when it
comes out it's gonna be a lovely
wonderful film and we'll see you guys
next time on another episode of not too
deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]